he's an American recording artist and
actor from Cleveland Ohio in 2009 his
debut single night and day reached the
top five of the Billboard charts he has
sold over five million digital singles
and has worked with some of the most
prominent artists in the music industry
his kid cootie and here his top ten
rules for success it's really just about
like the right timing and and having
some good stuff and just being creative
you know cuz that's happen about oh it's
like you know kids think that it's just
easy to get a deal and it's that's not
even like the half of it like getting a
deal is like very easy to do it is but
it's after that you know I'm saying what
you're gonna do and what kind of music
do you have like what kind of product
are you bringing to the table and I
think what made me you know kind of get
to where I'm at right now is because of
the originality and the music and the
fact that I was trying to push the
envelope on just everything genres and
music and I think that's what made me
more notice about everybody else you
know in the underground scene I always
kind of wild grew up always kind of felt
like outcasts you know in but instead of
like being worried about that but now
kind of like embraced it and that's why
I made such a leap creatively into my
music that's why we are hearing about me
because when I stop second-guessing
myself and going in that's when I
created that new new and day and night
and I'm saying it's been I've been
consistent ever since the mixtape and
album and all the features I've been
doing like ever since I made that change
within me it's been good at the end of
the day my mama told me don't let no one
break me at the end of the day nobody
can ever stop me it's just like those
things are true and I mean it's like
nobody can can be the commander of your
destiny but you
you know you know only if you let
somebody else take over but you always
have the power and have the control and
that's what people need to remember man
on that day-to-day is you know it
actually sparked more minds and how
people want to be more leaders and
followers I think people are just a
little scared that they'll lose the the
audience's attention which is the very
real fears I get it you know but it also
goes back to what I was saying I've just
been blessed with a fan base that like
you know it's into what I'm doing no
matter what you know and that's that's
just dope you know but the average
artists know they can't just experiment
and there's a fear where they might not
sell records and then that's bad for
business and this is a business you know
so you know it's it's understood why
most guys don't really do it you know I
would like to see people do it I feel
like this that's not an excuse so I feel
like there's a way where people can be a
little bit more creative and push the
envelope a lot more with the music where
it fits in in a in a way that makes
sense and it's true to their their art
in their formula I feel like that yeah
there's always a way to try something
new and be innovative and bring
something different to the table just
Dre's whole thought process how he's
just so thoughtful from the beats to
every little meticulous sound and I was
inspired by that you'll hear that in my
production you know my favorite
producers are as follows dr. Dre Swizz
Beatz Tim Berlin Kanye West no I'm
saying that's my four and of course you
know there's my family playing Pat in
the mill who are phenomenal who date
they eat humble pie every day they wake
up so you know you never get it out of
yeah yeah but those mom was a genius
they had to be to put me in the first
place to see it before I saw myself what
I could be yeah like so you know I'm
going into this project thinking about
those people like when I'm when I'm
gonna add a sound at the end or I want
to switch the beat up I'm like oh I used
to love but timber needs to switch the
beat up at the end and it would just be
a whole nother song on them there let me
try to do my own kind of flavor of that
you know
cannot recreate and reimagine this beat
in the same song you know before give
him a little some sound in the beginning
that they won't hear and today here at
the end you know I mean like this was
very like meticulous and strategic with
a lot of the production I'll nerd it out
a bit and that was the fun part that I
got to be a straight-up nerd on some of
the most aggressive and like hip-hop
public a dub look at Jean Rosa's
different races races in in this game
it's like hip-hop was one race and
rock'n'roll is another race and I'm
being so on and so forth what I'm doing
is trying to end the segregation between
genres you know I mean and kind of just
fusing them together and making it one
super song you know so to speak and
that's what I'm trying to do but just do
it in a way where it's like appropriate
not like just oh man I want to do a
record with this band because it's a
band and you need to fuse hip-hop with
alternative rock is because that's a new
thing to do so I'm just go get this band
to do this hook for me I'm gonna strap
on this rock and roll beat and it's like
no yeah I mean that's been done before
what's the neck cut you know me maybe
confuse alternative rock with some
electro and still put hip hop on it and
fuse all three of those together maybe
we could take some folk put some nice
drums on it and they pop drums and mix
it in with some country some guitar or
something here I mean and get-get like
someone like Lee Keely to jump on it and
really kill it on the hook side of
things give her a verse give me a verse
we do a duet you know I mean but at the
same time it's a song that you've never
heard before with the sound that you've
never you know heard before either you
know and it's done in a way where it's
like okay it's different but we it's
believable
it sounds good you know and and and Kid
Cudi is trying to execute that in a way
that nobody's ever done I wanted to
surpass day and night ten times over you
know I wanted to make this album like it
was my third
yeah man like I wanted to go in and just
no holds bar just come with it man cuz
it's like people didn't know what to
expect from me because of day and night
just being such a big success is I mean
sky kisses be a one-hit wonder and you
can just have all these really wack
songs after this but um I love that
pressure and I kind of took that and put
it into my creativity you know and just
really when it went in Mason yeah I find
that when you have your friends in the
studio you got you know a couple guys on
worldstar a couple guys on Twitter a
couple guys in here and everybody's
talking about what's going on over here
and what's going on here you're trying
to write this song you can distract you
next he knows two hours have gone by
he's still working on this record you
had some laughs but what you came to the
studio for is not done yet right you
know and there's money being spent
there's time time is of the essence this
is what we hustled and worked hard for
you know and I have to had to remind
myself it's like man this is turned into
a party night we're here for work
so I also have this like really gnarly
work ethic like cuz I've been working
since I was 15 my first job was Wendy's
I I remember why I wanted to work it was
because I wanted my own but I was tired
to asking my mom for stuff and also
didn't think it was fair you know to ask
my mom for stuff cuz I know we had much
so you know I just had that worked for
me as always like one of those things
that's reported I think that's important
you know in life to to know who you are
in order to progress and that's what
this album is about self-reflection and
at the end is being alright it's a new
day it's morning when you start right
you know I mean and being confident and
that's ultimately what men of the moon
is that's the message in this first
installment does hip-hop need to do I
think the braggadocio money cash hoes
thing needs to be dead
I feel like that's holding us back
as a culture as black people it doesn't
that doesn't advance us in any way shape
or form we've been doing that same theme
for years now it's been like what four
decades of the same old sorry for my
language mhm and I feel like you know if
you're gonna be an artist it's the time
where you just have to you know embrace
the the responsibility and understand
that the power of music is something so
special and be able to do it on this
magnitude where you reach millions of
people it's like why not use that for
good why not tell kids something that
they can connect with and use in their
life and like really my mission
statements since day one
and I'm getting so worked up talking
about this all I wanted to do was help
kids not feel alone and stop kids from
committing suicide
thank and and I'll never try to be
political I'm actually like shaking I
can't believe I'm saying this those two
specific things yeah yeah does that come
from well I dealt with suicide for the
past five years you know like there
wasn't a week or a day that didn't go by
where I was just like you know I want to
check out you know and I know what that
feels like and I know it comes from
loneliness I know it comes from not
having self-worth not loving yourself
and these are things that you know kids
don't have music that can coach them and
give them that guidance I didn't have
that I had to listen to jay-z and take
certain things from it and in the other
I just didn't know what he was talking
about yeah yeah they're like now I'm 30
and I'm like oh that's what hope was
talking about I get it now you know but
what about the kids who you know you've
never really had an artist when you
connect it with them all across the
board you know and I think that that's
my job I'm just really just trying to
guide people and help people cuz you
know loneliness is a terrible terrible
thing man and if you don't know how to
conquer it it can eat you alive thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Obi nough idioma
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of kit cooties top 10 rules
meant the most to you leave it in the
comments below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon